عارضه ازياء وممثله وموسيقيه ثم نجمه
تلفزيونيه وسينمائيه مشهوره هذا ما اصبحت
عليه كريستين ريتر الطفله بعد قطعها شوطا
طويلا في عقدين نجحت خلالهما في تقديم
افضل الادوار التلفزيونيه والسينمائيه فما
قصتها
ولدت كريستين عام
وترعرعت بمزرعه للماشيه بضواحي بنسلفانيا
في كان في والدتها وزوج والدتها حيث عاشت
تفاصيل الحياه الريفيه بحذافيرها فحلبت
الابقار واطعمت الدجاج واتقنت الاعمال
المنزليه كما كانت تعتني بعجل شكل جزءا
كبيرا من طفولتها وكانت قد اسمته جاك
اضافه الى كلب اليف اسمتهم مكي كانت
كريستين ترقص دائما وتحاول جذب الانتباه
بالصراخ معتبرته والدتها مؤشرا على توجهها
للنجوميه منذ البدايه بدات كريستين اثناء
دراستها الثانويه عروض الازياء قبل ان
تنتقل لنيويورك حيث تشاركت في غرفه واحده
مع 8 الى 10 فتيات وعاشت في غرفه باسره من
طابقين لكنها ايضا وجدت الطريق الى
العالميه وظهرت صورها في كتالوجات الازياء
العالميه كما قامت بعروض مهمه على المسارح
بنيويورك وميلانو وباريس وطوكيو كما انضمت
لفرقه
حيث قامت بالغناء وكتابه الاغاني وعزف
الجيتار بسبب شهرتها كعرضه ازياء حصلت
كريس لاحقا على فرص للظهور بادوار ثانويه
بالاعمال التلفزيونيه كدور طالبه في فيلم
موناليزا سمايل ثم ظهرت بشخصيه كي في
حلقات من مسلسل وان لايف توليب قبل ان
تحظى باول دور بطوله في عام 2006 بالفيلم
الكوميدي
الذي دفعها لدائره الضوء مع اعمال ناجحه
مثل
2011 ظهرت كريستين في ثلاثه افلام من
هوليود
ثم خاضت تجربه ناجحه بالمسرحيه
التلفزيونيه
لكن شهرتها الاكبر ارتبطت بشخصيه جيسيكا
جونز ضمن سلسله مارفلز وشخصيه
بالمسلسل التلفزيوني بريكنج باد حيث اصبح
يشار اليها بالبنان كما حصلت على ترشيحات
لجوائز مهمه وفازت بعدد منها ابرزها
خلال مسيرتها قدمت كريستين اكثر من 16
فيلما وجمعت ثروه تقدر بثمانيه ملايين
دولار وباتت الفتاه الريفيه تسكن في منزل
فاخر من الطراز الحديث يملاه اثاث فخم
ويحاط بحدائق وحمام سباحه
[موسيقى]